[Musique]
J'ai fait des rêves des plus étranges. Les
rêves de Rachel ne sont pas du
matériel analytique fiable, ils datent tellement du 20ème
siècle.
[Musique]
nous sommes ravis de vous faire savoir que
nous avons eu du mouvement sur
eux, nous avons une place au Womb Center
mais  Je ne l'ai pas encore dit à Albie oh pourquoi
Rachel
merci
[Musique]
il veut un enfant naturel
mais attends tu nous mets sur une liste d'attente pour
avoir un bébé avec un nom non ce n'est pas un œuf
c'est un œuf les
femmes sont réticentes à le faire  avoir des enfants
parce que ce n'est pas pratique nous voulons qu'ils
poursuivent leur carrière et leurs rêves
nous ne pouvons pas vivre dans le passé je veux avoir
un enfant avec toi faisons-le vraiment ouais
[Musique]
les parents en raffolent c'est la
solution ultra
mon neveu est né au Womb Center
mais il ne rêve pas je ne m'inquiéterais pas
pour ça
oh allez je ne peux pas le faire avec le pot
ici de quoi tu parles il ne peut pas
nous voir
je sens qu'Alvey l'est  capable de créer des liens avec un
enfant mais je ne le suis pas
peut-être que je ne suis tout simplement pas prête à être mère
tu sais que personne n'est une mère juste comme
ça tu le deviens une
ces derniers temps Je me suis accroché à quelque chose que
nous envisageons d'accoucher à domicile
Je suis désolé, ce n'est pas possible, je n'élèverai pas
cet enfant sans la nature,
félicitations,
c'est tellement excitant, n'est-ce pas,
j'ai remarqué un changement dans la proactivité, vous
avez un bébé au centre de l'utérus, pourquoi
[Musique] la
dynamique de votre famille est sur le point de le faire.
subir d'énormes changements,
comment pouvons-nous nous assurer que notre bébé ne
s'ennuie pas in utero oh ouais, nous ne voulons pas que les
bébés s'ennuient